imagine a microscopic size ladder
contained in the part of our brain that
will label our subconscious the ladder
of inference which was first proposed by
Harvard professor Chris Argyris is the
basis of this model
every time we interact with someone that
experience enters the ladder at the
bottom that same experience zips up the
ladder in the blink of an eye
exiting at the top this process happens
thousands of times a day without us
knowing it let's focus on what happens
on each rung of the ladder on the first
rung we have the raw data and
observations of our experience this is
very similar to what someone watching a
video recording of our experience with
see moving up to the second rung we
filter in specific information in
details from our experience we
unknowingly filter based on our
preferences tendencies and many other
aspects that we believe are important
onto the third rung we assign meaning to
the information we have filtered through
this is where we start to interpret what
our information is telling us on the
fourth rung a very crucial thing happens
we develop assumptions based on the
meaning we created on the previous rung
and we start to blur the distinction
between what is fact and what is story
on the fifth rung we develop conclusions
based on our assumptions this is also
where our emotional reactions are
created on the sixth rung we adjust our
beliefs about the world around us
including the person or people involved
in our experience of the moment on the
seventh and final rung we take action
based on our adjusted beliefs still with
me great let's take a real-life example
and run it up the ladder to see how this
all works have you ever been cut off in
a parking lot signal light on as you
steer toward your coveted spot only to
slam on your brakes at the last minute
as someone pulls in front of you and
steals your spot away
imagine that experience and notice all
of the data and observations landing on
the first rung of your ladder now let's
watch what we pay attention to on the
second
who cares that sunny oh the birds are
chirping the 50% off sign outside of
your favorite stores meaningless you
filter in the sensation of your grip
tightening on the wheel you feel your
blood pressure rise you'd hear the
squeal of your brakes and you notice the
expression on the face of the other
drivers he pulls in front of you and
quickly looks away time for our third
rung ever since you were young your
parents taught you the importance of
waiting in line and taking your turn you
live and die by the rule of first-come
first-serve
and now this guy is just thawing your
spot what gives up to the fourth rung we
go
watch closely as our assumptions take
over and our story creates itself that's
stupid jerk didn't his parents teach him
anything how could he not see my signal
late he must never pay attention why
does he think he's more important than
anyone else jumping quickly to the fifth
rung we conclude that this guy is
heartless inconsiderate he needs to be
taught a lesson and put in his place we
feel angry frustrated vindictive
justified on our sixth rung we adjust
her beliefs based on the experience
that's the last time I give in next time
someone tries to cut me off tires will
be smoking on the pavement as I squeal
past them into my spot and finally our
last rung we take action we back up pull
up behind his car honk our horns and
roll down her window to Scruton feet
now imagine he walks over quickly
apologizing his wife who has almost do
with their first baby called him from
inside the mall to say she is in labor
and needs to get to the hospital
immediately
we are momentarily shocked apologized
profusely and wish him luck as he rushes
toward the entrance what just happened
here what changed why is this so
significant in our parking lot example
our beliefs were short-circuited by the
latter of the other individual my wife
is in labor I need to get there quick
there's a parking spot pew oh jeez I cut
someone off I better apologize quickly
so they don't think I'm a jerk but what
if we were able to short-circuit our
letters ourselves proactively by choice
guess what we can let's return to our
unique human function of free will
next time you notice yourself reacting
to your experience pay focused attention
to your ladder
ask yourself what beliefs are at play
where did they come from what data and
observations did you filter in as a
result of your beliefs and why are your
assumptions valid and supported by facts
what a different set of assumptions
create different feelings and result in
new and better conclusions and actions
we all have our own unique ladder be
mindful of yours and help others to see
theirs
you